[Music]
hello everyone welcome to this morning's
session on test-driven development for
the Android platform my name is Jonathan
garish and I'm part of the mobile ninjas
we're a small team within Google who are
passionate about software testing and
can I get a quick show of hands in the
audience how many of you are actually
writing tests as part of your normal
software development practice that's
fantastic
okay so if you've written tests for
Android before you probably use some of
our tools we developed the Android
testing support library which includes
the J unit for test run own rules
the espresso UI testing framework and
were also active contributors to
robolectric the open-source Android unit
testing framework so everyone's telling
you to write tests but why should you
really do it it's true that tests take
time to write they're adding code to
your codebase and perhaps you've been in
a situation before where your manager or
client has been telling you that they're
slowing you down
but there's so many compelling reasons
to write tests tests give you rapid
feedback on failures so failures that
are spotted earlier on in the
development cycle a far easier to fix
than once they've gone live secondly
tests give you a safety net you're free
with a good suite of tests you're free
to refactor clean up and optimize your
code safe in the knowledge that you're
not going to break existing behavior
tests are really the backbone of
sustainable software development you'll
be able to maintain a stable velocity
throughout the lifetime of your project
and you're going to avoid the boom-bust
cycles of crunch feature time and the
aggregation of technical debt so in
software testing there exists the
concept of the pyramid the testing
pyramid and this is made up of a number
of layers and each layer brings with it
its own trade-offs that you're going to
have to weigh at the lowest layer is the
small tests or the unit tests and these
need to be very fast and highly focused
that's why we recommended you
these kind of tests is what is known as
local unit tests and these are going to
run on your local desktop machine and
the trade-off you're making with these
kind of tests is infidelity because
you're not running on a realistic
environment and you're probably
substituting in a bunch of marks and
fakes as we move up the pyramid we're
now into the realms of integration
testing and end-to-end testing and the
key with these kind of tests is to bring
in fidelity that's why we recommend that
you run these kind of tests on a real
device or an emulator these are the kind
of tests that are going to tell you that
your software actually works
however they are less focused so a
failure in one of these kind of tests
might take a little longer to track down
that it would in a unit test and one of
the big trade-offs you're making is in
test execution speed because you're
assembling multiple components they all
have to be built and then package
shipped to a device where the tests are
run and the results elected back that's
going to take extra time so there's no
single layer in this testing pyramid
that can suffice so what you need to do
is to blend in tests at each different
tier leveraging the strengths of one
category to way off the trade-offs in
another there's no real hard and fast
rule here but Google's own internal
testing experts recommend the 70-20-10
rule of thumb as the ratio between small
medium and large tests let's take a look
at our workflow so and with test-driven
development the idea is that you start
by writing your tests then you implement
a code to make those tests pass and then
when your tests a green you can submit
again a quick show of hands who out
there has test-driven their code tried
test-driven development in the past okay
cool so we like test-driven development
because it makes you to think about the
design of your application up front it
gives you consideration to api's and the
structure of your code with test-driven
development you're also going to be
writing less code because you only write
the code necessary to satisfy your tests
this will enable you to release
and often as you constantly green you'll
be able to deploy a working application
at a moment's notice
if we're following the test pyramid the
workflow is going to look something like
this first of all we have a larger outer
iteration that's concerned with feature
development and here is started it's
driven by a UI test and the mantra with
test-driven development is red green
refactor we start off with a failing
test we implement the code to make that
test pass and then we refactor inside
the larger iteration are a series of
smaller iterations and these are
concerned with the unit tests here that
you're assembling the building the units
required to make the feature pass and
again you use the same mantra here red
green refactor red green refactor so
let's take a look an example application
so the feature going to implement today
is the add notes flow to a sample note
taking application if we take a look at
our mock-ups we can see that we start on
a notes list screen full of some
existing notes there's a floating action
button down at the bottom and the user
will click this taking them on to the
new add notes screen here they can enter
a title and a description for their note
before clicking save the node will be
persisted and then never turned back to
the notes list screen where they can see
their newly added note along with any
other notes that previously existed so
coming back to our workflow for a moment
remember that we start with a failing UI
test so let's take a look at how this
test would look like using espresso the
UI testing framework the first step is
to click on the add node button then we
enter the title and description and
click Save before returning to the notes
list screen and here we're going to
verify that the note that we just added
actually shows up now remember with
test-driven development
we're not implement the code just yet
and all we have to do is implement
enough of the application to satisfy the
specification of our tests so an empty
activity and just the resources that we
need will
fyz once we have that we can run our
test and we'll see it'll fail now we
have to implement this feature so
applications are built up of many small
units these are small highly focused
specialized components that do one thing
and they do it well collections these
small units are then assembled together
so that they're collaborations will
satisfy our feature let's take a moment
to summarize the key characteristics of
make up a good unit test as well as the
normal conditions you wanting to start
you wanting to test your failure
conditions invalid inputs and boundary
conditions you can end up writing a lot
of unit tests unit tests must always
give you the same result every time so
avoid depending on things that might
change for example an external server or
the current time of date because this is
going to bring flakiness into your unit
tests unit tests should exercise one
specific aspect of your code at a time
you wanting to see that a failure in a
unit test will lead you very quickly to
an actual bug in your code and when you
write unit tests avoid making too many
assumptions on the actual implementation
of your code you want your unit has to
test behavior that way you avoid
rewriting your tests when your
implementations changing and one of the
most important aspects of unit test is
they've got to be fast especially
because you're writing so many of them
and you're in TDD workflow running them
rapidly and it would it would be
terrible if they were you were
discouraged from writing tests or
refactoring your code because of the
pain in the execution time of those
tests and finally unit tests are an
excellent source of documentation and
the way that's constantly evolving with
your code as it changes unlike static
documents that will stagnate over time
let's write a unit test for our add
notes activity this activity is going to
take in
user input and then we're going to
persist it to local storage on the
device okay so we're going to create the
add note activity class and the select
stand activity which is an android
framework class it has a view which is
going to be inflated with a layout and
the user will enter their data here and
then we're going to persist that note
into Android shared preferences
mechanism so it's conceivable that as
our application evolves so does our
requirement and perhaps our storage
requirements evolve to persist the notes
on to cloud storage and we have to build
some kind of synchronization mechanism
for local storage for the offline use
case and in these cases we see
opportunities for abstraction we might
in this example see that we can extract
a notes repository and however one of
the key aspects of test-driven
development is that we only start by
writing the simplest case first and then
we iterate so we're going to resist the
temptation to do this early let's take a
look at a sample of what an idealized
unit test would look like they're
generally built up into three stages so
the first stage is you're setting the
conditions for the test and this
includes preparing the environment
setting up your dependencies with a
required state and preparing an input
data
next we'll exercise the code under test
before finally making assertions on the
results or the state so I like to
clearly separate each of these three
stages of the tests and bring the
pertinent aspects of each test like
front and center to make for really
readable test so up until now with the
Android platform you're writing your
unit tests using the mockable jar in
conjunction with a marking library such
as mojito and let's take a look at an
example of our test written with mojito
okay wow that's a lot of code
okay so because of we have so many
interactions with the android framework
and we're going to need to provide
stubbing behavior for all of them in
order just to make just to satisfy the
execution paths of our tests and
furthermore because Android uses a lot
of static methods we're forced to
introduce a second mocking library power
mark that will handle this special case
for us and there are also some pretty
bad code smells here let's take a look
you see we're forced to spy on the
activity under test and we're needing to
do this to modify its behavior and
stubbing it out and providing some no
ops so we're moving out of the realms of
blackbox testing here and finally at the
end we're making assertions about the
implementation details and if these
change our tests will need to change too
so remembering the characteristics of a
good unit test let's take a moment to
score this particular test well it is
very focused we're just testing the
happy path of our add notes flow and
it's certainly fast because it's running
on the local JVM however we were making
rather a lot of assumptions about the
implementation in that test and and with
this if any of our implementation
changes it's likely we'll need to
rewrite that test substantially and
finally all that excess boilerplate
stubbing is really distracting it's
distracting away from the key aspects of
the test the conditions the tests that
you're trying to document well luckily
there's a tool that helps address some
of these issues so introducing Robo
electric robolectric is an Android unit
testing tool that's open source that we
are actively contributing to and to tell
you more about how you can write great
tests with robolectric i'm going to hand
you over to christian williams the
original author of robolectric
thanks Jonathan it's awesome to see so
many people who are into Android testing
and TDD so yeah rub electric is this a
scrappy little open-source project that
I started hacking on back in the early
days of Android testing because I was
just super annoyed at how long it took
to to deploy and run tests on an
emulator and it's kind of been a side
project of a bunch of different people
until last year when I had the privilege
of joining my friend Jonathan at Google
where he was already working on
improving robolectric
for Google's of internal test Suites and
since then we've been we've been really
beefing up for electric and contributing
back to the open source project today
robolectric isn't an officially
supported part of the android plus
testing platform but we found that when
it's used correctly it can be a really
useful part of your testing strategy and
i'm going to show you a little bit about
how you can how you can do that too so
let's go back to our note student test
and see how we might approach it with
robolectric
so since rubb electric runs as a local
unit test it'll still be running in your
workstation rather than an emulator but
robolectric provides kind of a little
Android sandbox next to your test where
the actual SDK code is running you'll
have access to your activities your
layouts and views and resources and you
can generally just call most Android
methods and they'll kind of work like
you'd expect there are parts of the
android framework that rely on on native
code or call it hardware or interact
with external system services so for
that robolectric provides a sort of test
double that we call shadows and those
provide alternative limitations of that
code that's appropriate for unit testing
so remember that that test that we just
saw if it had like 20 lines of code of
like mock set up code let's see how that
looks in robolectric so that's a lot
less we've gotten rid of all the
boilerplate
the test is about half the size and much
more concise we're not forced to think
about the implementation details as
we're writing the test
which is quite nice Reb logic is going
to set up your application according to
your manifest and here we're asking it
to set up our activity it runs it
through the appropriate life cycle to
get it into the right state inflates
views all that stuff it that we expect
from on a device so we can just interact
with it as if you're on the device so we
add some texts and fields click on it
and assert that it adds the note to the
repository now notice that we're not
actually going as far as the UI test
that we saw that we wrote at the very
beginning
we're not asserting that the new note
appears on a view screen that would be
the job of another unit test
now I mentioned robolectric shadows they
actually give extended testing api's to
some Android classes that let us let us
query internal state and sometimes
change your behavior in this example
we're asking the application if any of
our activities requested that an intent
be launched during the test we could use
that twister that after saving a note to
the repository we're going to go to the
to the view notes activity similar
testing api's exists for simulating
Hardware responses or external services
things like that so at this point we
have a failing unit test and now we get
to we're ready for the easy part writing
the production code in the spirit of TDD
we're only going to write exactly as
much as as is needed to make the test
pass no more no speculative coding so we
inflate a layout at acetic Handler and
when the click happens we like for you
to note an editor
repository so now we can run the test
see a pass if there's some improvement
we can make to the code we'll go back
and refactor and then we repeat this is
where you get the thoroughness and Rev
electric is super handy for this because
it gives you like nice fast test runs
you can get into a comfy cycle so we
want to not discuss the happy path here
we're going to test all the different
cases we can there are codes likely to
encounter so for example input
validation and external conditions like
the network being down stuff like that
Rob let you can also help with
simulating device conditions that you'll
encounter for example you can specify
qualifiers at the notes or that the test
should run with here we're saying like a
certain screen size and orientation
which might change the layout a bit you
can ask your lecturer to run your test
under a specific SDK so we'll say jelly
bean here and it actually uses the SDK
code from that version and you can also
tell Rob Electric I want to run this
test under every SDK that you support or
some some range of them that you're
interested in and we support jelly bean
through oh right now so at Google we
rely really heavily on robolectric and
we're investing making it better
we've got dozens of apps including these
that have hundreds of thousands of unit
tests running internally so it's well
battle tested and we've also recently
started running the Android CTS which is
a dandy official Android test suite
again strobe electric and we're about 70
percent passing right now getting better
with every release so if you've used our
electric in the past and found that it's
come up short or if you're stuck in an
old version definitely recommend that
you you get up to the latest because
it's been a long way we've been working
on reducing friction and then in
integrating Rev electric with Android
toolchain
it works now very well with
with Android studio with Gradle and
we've got support for Basile Google's
into Google's own open-source build
system coming soon so robolectric isn't
a one-size-fits-all testing tool it's
fast but it's not a hundred percent
identical to Android in every way so you
want to use it judiciously as we said
before avoid writing unit tests that
link multiple activities together that's
not so much a unit test that's much
better for espresso if you find yourself
dealing with multiple threads
synchronization issues stuff like that
you're also probably not writing a unit
test so not good for electric and
particularly avoid using robolectric to
test reintegration with with android api
s and things like Google Play services
you really need to have higher level
tests to give you confidence that that's
working so now that we've got some
passing unit tests I'm going to have you
over to my colleague Stephan to talk
about our level testing
Thank You Christian so let's go back to
our developer workflow diagram and so at
this point we hopefully have a ton of
unit tests and they thoroughly test all
our business logic but let's switch
gears and try to see how we can actually
write some integration tests to see how
these units integrate and how they
actually integrate with Android and how
they run in a real environment so on
Android these tests are usually referred
to as instrumentation tests and I'm
pretty sure most of you have written an
instrumentation test before and even
though they look super simple on the
surface there's actually a lot going on
under the hood if you think about it you
have to compile the code you have to
process your resources you have to bring
up a full system image and then run your
tests and there's a lot of things that
go on on various levels of the Android
stack so these tests give you high
fidelity but as John was mentioning they
come at a cost which is they're slower
and sometimes they're more flaky than
unit tests so let's actually see how
this works in your day-to-day
development flow so let's say you're in
Android studio you've just written your
you know new espresso test and you hit
the Run button to run the test so the
first thing that Android studio is going
to do is it's going to install two apks
for you the test apk and the app under
test so now the test APK contains
Android JUnit runner it contains the
test cases and your test manifest and
then in order to run the test Android
studio calls under the hood adb shell am
instrument and then Android Jade runner
will use instrumentation to control your
app under test so what is
instrumentation and I think you guys may
have you guys may have noticed this it's
a top-level tag in your manifest and why
is that instrumentation is actually
something that you know it's used deeply
inside the android framework and it's
used to control the life cycle of your
activities for end
so if you think about it it's a perfect
interception point that we can use to
inject the test runner and that's why
Android drainage runner is not nothing
more or less than an instrumentation so
let's go a little bit deeper and see
what happens when Android studio
actually runs your tests so it runs adb
shell am instrument which will end up
calling out to activity manager activity
manager will then call at one point on
create on your instrumentation so now
that we know that Android Jayne Runner
is our instrumentation
at this point it will call on create on
the on the runner and then the runner is
gonna do a few things for you it's going
to collect all your tasks then it's
going to run all these tests
sequentially and then it's reporting
back the results one thing to note here
is that Android JUnit runner and you may
have noticed this runs in the same
process than your application and more
importantly if you usually use Android
join runner it runs all the tests in one
single instrumentation invocation
Android join each runner is heavily used
inside Google we run billions of tests
each month using Android JUnit runner
and while doing so we saw some
challenges that would that we face than
if we had to solve one thing that we see
a lot is shared state and I'm not
talking about the kind of like shared
state that you control and you that you
code in your app I'm talking about the
shared state that builds up on memory
builds up on disk and makes you it has
fail for you know no reason or you know
unpredictable conditions and this among
other things well at one point lead to
crashes but in the previous model that I
just showed you if if one of your tests
crashes your instrumentation it will
take the whole instrument the whole app
process with it and all the subsequent
tests will not run anymore and this is
obviously a problem for large test
suites similarly if you think about
debugging if you run a couple of
thousand tests in one invocation
think about what your Lochhead will look
like and when you have to go for it for
debugging so that's why inside of Google
we have taken a different approach so
inside of Google every test runs in
every test method runs in its own
instrumentation invocation so now you
can do this today right you can you know
make multiple adb calls you can use a
runner arc and maintain your custom
script but the problem is it might not
really integrate well with your
development environment so that's why
today I'm happy to announce the Android
test Orchestrator and the Android test
Orchestrator is a way that allows you to
run tests like we do in Google it's a
service ivk that runs in a background
and runs each test in a single
instrumentation invocation and this
obviously has benefits right there's no
shirt slate anymore
and in fact the Android test
Orchestrator runs p.m. clear before it
runs its test more so crashes are now
completely isolated because we have
single instrumentation invocations if a
crash happens all the subsequent tests
will still run and similarly for
debugging all the debugging information
that you collect and pull off the device
is now scoped to a particular test and
this is great and this is great and we
benefit a lot from it inside of Google
so let's see how it actually works so on
top of installing the test apk and upon
our test what we do now is we install a
third apk on the device and it's a
service apk running in the background
containing the orchestrator and then
instead of running multiple adb commands
we run a single ATB command but we don't
instrument the app under test we
instrument the orchestrator directly and
then the orchestrator is going to do all
its work on the device so it's going to
use android change runner to collect
your tests but then it's going to run
each of those tests in its own
invocation
and it's amazing and I'm pretty sure you
will you will like this a lot and it
will be available in the next Android
testing support library release and more
importantly we will have integration
with Android studio it will be available
in Gradle and we will also have
integration with firebase test lab
coming later this year so now that we
know how to run our tests let's actually
look at how we can write these
integration tests and usually if you
write a UI test on Android you're using
the espresso testing framework and as
you can see espresso has this like nice
and simple API and it actually works
pretty simple what it does is you give
us a view matcher and we find a view in
the hierarchy that matches that matcher
and then we either perform a view action
or check a view assertion and because
this API is so simple it's the perfect
tool to for fast TDD prototyping of UI
tests but in order to provide you such a
simple API there's a lot of things that
need to go on under the hood so let's
actually look how espresso let's look at
how spresso works
so when you call on view and give us
your matcher the first thing that we're
going to do is we're going to create a
view interaction for you and then the
next thing is we make sure that your app
is in an idle insane state before we are
ready to interact with it and this is
you can think of it this is at the core
of espresso and espresso is well-known
for it like synchronization guarantees
and the way we do it is we loop the
message queue until there are no
messages for a reasonable amount of time
we look at all your Eiling resources and
make sure they're idle and we also look
at async tasks to make sure there is no
background work running and only if we
know that your app is in a sane and
stable State and we're ready to interact
we're going to move on and then we're
going to traverse the view hierarchy and
find the view that matches your matcher
and once we have the view we then going
to perform a view action or a view
certian
and this is great so now let's circle
back to the test that we showed you in
the beginning and have a closer look now
that we know how its pressure works so
in the first line as you may remember we
try to click on the add node button and
here we just going to use a width ID
matter which is a simple matter that is
matching a view in the view hierarchy
according to its ID and next thing we
want to do is we want to click on the
view and we use a click view action for
this so now where it gets interesting is
the next line because on this line we
want to type the title and description
and we want to use a type text action
for that but here all the espresso
synchronisation guarantees will kick in
and only if we know that we're ready to
interact with your implication we're
going to invoke the type test action and
this is great
because it frees you from adding you
know additional boilerplate code and
additional slipping code to your test so
similarly we're going to save the node
and then we're going to verify that it's
displayed on screen and this is great
now we know how espresso works and we
know how it's a great tool to do
test-driven development and now I'm
going to hand over to Nick to talk a
little bit more on how you can improve
your UI test and how to improve your
large and medium testing strategy thank
you so fun
so one good attribute of a UI test is a
test that never sleeps so let's go back
to our example to illustrate this point
a little bit further so in our examples
you remember we have a note that we save
into memory which is pretty fast and
pretty reliable
however reliably reality as your app
grows you probably want to extend this
functionality and save your note to the
cloud or Google Drive for example so
when running our large end-to-end test
we want to use a real environment where
we hit the real server and depending on
your network connection this may take a
long time so you probably want to do is
in the background now the problem is now
is that espresso synchronization is not
aware of any of your long-running tasks
so this is somewhere that some where
developers will probably do something as
ugly as putting a thread sleep in their
code but what this presser is not
actually required because you can write
an idling resource where an idling
resource is a simple interface for you
as a developer to implement to teach
espresso synchronization of any of your
custom long running tasks of your app so
with this ionic resource we made our
large end-to-end test more reliable so
let's see how we can add some more
medium-sized stats to your test suite so
for a medium-sized test we want to keep
them small and focused on a single UI
component whereas single UI component
may be like a specific view fragment or
an activity so let's go back to our
example to see how we can isolate our
large end-to-end test to more isolated
components so here in this example again
you may have noticed that there are two
activities the list activity on the left
and the add node activity on the right
so until now we wrote a large end-to-end
test that gives us a lot of confidence
because it touches upon a lot of your
code in your app which is great for
large intent test but it's not so great
for an iterative test-driven development
cycle so so let's see how we can isolate
these and have isolated tests for each
activity in isolation to isolate the
left-hand side the list activity we can
use espresso intense
we're espresso intense is a simple API
that allows you to intercept any of you
are going a tense verify their content
and provide back a mock activity result
great so let's see how that API actually
looks like so as you can see it's very
straightforward you have an intent
matcher
that will match your going intent and
you can provide a version of your
activity result back to the caller
okay so let's use this API to write our
first isolated test so in this test you
can see on the first line we do exactly
that we intercept our intent and we
provide a stub version of our activity
result now on the second line when we
perform click instead of starting a new
activity espresso will intercept this
intent and provide a subjective result
which we can then use on the last line
to verify that our UI was updated
accordingly now we have an isolated test
okay so let's go back to our example and
see how we can isolate the second part
right so when you write when usually
write tests you end up in a position
where you may have some external
dependencies in play that can check that
are outside of your control so in our
example right as I showed before we have
I know that we save and it hits the real
server now even though we have an
auditing resource now that makes it more
reliable your tests can still fail
because your server may crash for some
reason so your test will fail so
wouldn't be better if we completely
isolate ourselves from these conditions
and run our tests in a hermetic
environment this will not only make your
test run much faster but it will also
eliminate any flakiness and beyond this
specific example you further want to
isolate yourself from any external
dependencies so for example you don't
want to test any Android system UI or
any other UI components that you don't
own because they probably already tested
and they can also change without your
knowing so your tests will actually fail
so let's see how our second isolated
test will look like in code
so here we see the main point here is
that we no longer use the real server
and instead you know we set up a
hermetic repository now there's many
different ways of you to do this and
this is just one way so then you can use
this harmonic repository in order to
verify that your note is actually saved
without ever leaving the context of your
app or hitting the network so at this
point if you think about it you have two
smaller tests that run much more they
are way more reliable and run much
faster but at the same time you maintain
the same amount of test coverage as your
large end-to-end test and this is why we
want to have more of these smaller
isolated tests compared to the large
end-to-end tests we showed before okay
so at this point we iterated through our
developer cycle a few times and we
should see all of our tests start
turning green and we should be confident
to release our feature however before we
conclude let's jump into the future for
a second
as your app grows and your team grows
you continue adding more and more
features to your app and you may find
yourself in a position where you may
have UI running in multiple processes
which is exactly what happened at Google
so if you go to our notes example this
may look something like this you have a
first activity that runs in your main
process on the left-hand side and now
the second activity will run in us in a
private process and in this case we're
going to call it add notes so how do we
test that well before Android oh it was
impossible to test but with Android oh
there is a new instrumentation attribute
that you can use in order to define
which process you want to instrument
while instrumenting and running tests
against each process in isolation is a
great idea and you should do it you may
find yourself in a position where you
want to cross process boundaries within
one test so you would probably want to
write an espresso test like looks like
this while this was not only possible in
a framework level before Android oh this
was also impossible
on this first level because in this
specific example Express is not even
aware of your secondary process nor can
it maintain any of the synchronization
guarantees we all know and love so today
I'm happy to announce multi-process
espresso support without changing any of
your test code or your app code this
will allow you to seamlessly interact
with UI cross process while maintaining
all of us presto synchronization
guarantees and it will be able available
in the next version of Android test
support library release so let's have a
quick overview of how it actually works
so traditionally as you know in our
example we start in one process where we
have an instance of an original runner
and espresso in this case now if you
remember from our example when you click
the add node button there will be a new
activity and now we have a new process
so the problem now is that we have two
processes with two different instances
of an original runner and espresso and
they're not aware of each other so the
first thing that we want to do is we
want to establish communication between
the two and regenerate runner and now
that we have this communication we can
use it to establish the communication
video to espresso instances and the way
we do that is by having an ability in
hydrogen as runner to register any
testing frameworks like espresso with an
original runner and then the runner will
then facilitate all the handshaking
required in order to establish
communication between the two espresso
instances now that the two inspiration
instances can talk to each other it can
then use it in order to enable cross
process testing and maintaining all the
synchronization guarantees that we had
before okay so with that we're reaching
the end of our developer workflow and we
showed you all the tools that you can
use across each step of the way in order
to make TDD happen and on Android and
with that said even if you don't follow
this flow exactly hopefully you know how
to use every single tool and how to
write good tests in order to bring your
app quality to the next level
so if you like to write tests and you
want to write an on test like we do at
Google here are some resources to get
you started but I want to thank you and
I think we have some time for questions
and if not we we have office hours at
3:30 today so hopefully you see that
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]